if there's an artist that's watching
this that's on the come up
would you give them advice to stay
independent
or go with a major
let's say they got a little bit of
momentum it's different for different
artists everyone's situation is
different but yeah because there's
certain artists who i
never think should go to a major and
certain ones who i think
need to go to a major so they can get
the looks so who do you think like like
like like talk about the type of artist
you think would need to go to a major
and or should stay independent
like an example i think like from my
perspective if you have like a song that
goes viral but you really don't have a
following
yeah like you might want to go the major
route right right because
then you they'll maximize that record
because that record might be the only
opportunity you have right let's say
like that board in the house kid right
uh-huh
you had that record that went viral yeah
i haven't heard from him since but he
signed a deal and then they put the
tiger on the remix and i think that was
probably a smart play for him
definitely a smart player if it's
somebody who's got a crazy following
right like russ or somebody or let's use
let's use like
blast citizens last like so is he is he
signed to a major
no he's got a partnership with red with
rebel music i think that that's somebody
probably
who's really dope and will succeed
doing their independent thing but if he
was assigned to a major could he be way
more why
artists absolutely so you think or like
that's like saying if
if roddy rich didn't assign to a major
or just stayed independent do i think
you know what i'm saying yeah i think
roddy richard a major is
so you think the last set of majors just
because the last that blast at a major
is essentially a little solidifying as a
superstar
yeah yeah i i think so because he has
those type of records that i think get
overlooked
that are way that are huge you know what
i'm saying or you know i'm saying radio
ready or just a single that
everyone will like just because it
sounds sonically just good
so glass is an alien have you worked
have you got to link with him at all no
i feel like you guys were that
yeah i think so i was definitely a fan
uh
early and then you know what i'm saying
i'm somebody too because it's like i'll
be a fan of people
and then once they get like their wave
going
i hit people up and be like congrats to
this and that and then i don't i feel
like i'd be seeming like the person who
hopped on the wave
right more so than i'm just like seeing
it like from the outside like dang i
watch you grind up i remember when i was
the only person listening to you and
then i hit you and then
you might think like dang they just
trying to hop on the way have you
reached out to blast
uh i don't remember if i reached out to
bla i know i follow him i feel like i
might have sent blasts to dm or
something
or yeah i
yeah i got a record with beno right now
and uh i remember that's kind of where i
heard blast was from ladino
had a record so uh but now i planned on
reaching out
you know i'm saying i was letting it
just that might be a vibe you
in blast i think that would be easy body
because i i hear when i hear it i hear
already what i would would do and how
comfortable that would be hey he's
working man i know he works with mozzie
a lot you know obviously him and bino
got i think they're working on
us follow up to their tape but you know
he's going crazy right here no he's
definitely going crazy he's dope to see
that
for sure yeah that'd be that'd be wild
that'd be that might be like
that has to happen yeah i think that has
to happen i mean honestly i was thinking
about it like like if you're gonna come
back with like one of them r b type
records it's gotta be blast yeah